підвалі влади чи музи амстердама
вже два рок і застрягла так звані кицьки
золотом за нього beauty україна то музи
окупованого росію кримом pro-t
жадібного доступу до експонатів вони для
журналістів вони для
до starring конфлікту на травневий музей вигляд
виявляючи всіх до суду, а сама про studio
окружного адміністративного суду
амстердама
цієї петля 2 руки в суп і річкою
наріжте виріж і
понапі в 1000 експонатів моїх ніби
передо і
україні аргументація просто золото
скіфів я культурну врятованої України
вона регіону клінтона момент висновків не
експонаті їх пиво стрілянину в іншу
україни представлені кримськими музеями
ціни за одним за моїми уявленнями на
мою думку було у хвала на політичне
рішення там вухах. здуру музою нойз
праві гарчать slide повернуть іти двері
зико ихвани вийшли про дику менше рішення
на поверхню практику та логіку
музейне право логіка музейної справи
своїх емоцій сторона щуп грала на
пухові пьюдса збентежив його я і обіцяти у
скаже і рішення суду націлених е3 my
city
я помираю від них годин до розряду
апеляції золото скіфів і далили стиснутому
підвалі музи алларда персона за кущ
україни думають запилювати і ще змінити
кут ванної навіть валики сум його ще до
того чиї мають його недоліки аргументів
для пари року рішення то чоловік мій
думку рішення читання підтвердила
міжнародні відведення юнеско і право
суверенної україни топ то україни ви
магате назад свою культурну спадщину
по прямому шляху україна травні згуртує і
112 тисяч євро до музею за заощадження
скорботи втім 2 руки
а також транспорт його не і дух його тем
годиною сторони опонент mais під цією
суду і витрати цех миші 3 тисячі євро